je trouve ça assez étrange parce que je
ne pensais pas que la droite serait
aussi démissionnaire dans le débat
c'est-à-dire que le Parlement du débat
on a suffisamment dit qu'à l'Assemblée
il n'y avait pas eu de débat pas
suffisamment pas avec le ton qui
convenait bref ici tout ça se passe de
manière très courtoise bon comme on le
fait souvent au Sénat mais nous n'avons
aucun interlocuteur c'est assez curieux
donc voilà il y a un certain nombre de
sénateurs de droites qui sont là mais
qui ne disent pas un mot et qui ne
défende pas davantage quelque chose dont
j'ai compris pourtant qui s'apprêtait à
le voter la droite dit notamment ce que
dit Bruno Retailleau en séance que ce
sont les rapporteurs à la fois Madame
douano et Monsieur Savary qui tiennent
l'opinion qui qui vont comme ça qui ont
porté la vie de la majorité de la moitié
du centre dans l'hémicycle qu'est-ce que
vous lui répondez avec taillot mais
c'est une faute de dire ça parce que les
rapporteurs portent la vie de la
Commission ne porte pas la vie d'un
groupe heureusement donc lorsqu'il dit
ça en fait il a dû penser
qu'effectivement c'était un peu étrange
que personne de son groupe ne s'exprime
et donc il a trouvé cette explication
qui ne tient pas et qui est même
choquante est-ce que c'est pas aussi la
faute de la gauche avec ces très
nombreuses amendements ces explications
de vote on comprend que vous vouliez
occuper le terrain pour et bien dénoncer
cette réforme mais est-ce que cela aussi
est bien n'empêche pas le débat alors ce
qui est très frappant mais comme vous
suivez le débat vous l'avez sans doute
constaté c'est que nous ne anodons pas
le même argumentaire à chaque fois
c'est-à-dire que nous sommes très
nombreux l'ensemble de la gauche et nous
défendons donc nos positions par exemple
nous sommes contre la suppression des
régimes spéciaux sur chaque régime vous
êtes en train de prendre la parole pour
défendre à chaque fois chacun des cinq
régimes qui qui est supprimé par la
réforme à chaque fois vous l'avez sans
doute noté avec des points de vue qui
sont illustrés différents donc
c'est vraiment moi je trouve que c'est
un débat intéressant c'est d'autant plus
profond c'est même un peu problématique
du coup la droite n'explique pas parce
que moi je serais contente de savoir
pourquoi on a choisi de supprimer le
régime spécial je sais pas de la RATP et
pas des dockers de d'éclairs de notaire
et pas de la Comédie française alors
comment est-ce que vous l'expliquez vous
l'avez vous avez parlé de bâillon
Retailleau dans l'hémicycle c'est quoi
ce qui se joue en coulisses c'est que la
droite est d'accord avec le gouvernement
et du coup soit avancer sur cette
réforme je pense que LR fait le calcul
je ne suis pas sûr qu'il soit gagnant
pour eux mais c'est leur problème que au
final ce texte sera le leur et que donc
ça montrera leur puissance politique
dans En attendant il ne s'exprime pas et
ne défende pas le texte donc un côté
stablement il y a une consigne de
silence qui a été donnée puisque y
compris les rares amendements qui ont pu
être déposés très très rare par des élus
de droite ne sont parfois pas défendues
voir retirées et même lorsqu'ils sont
maintenus au moment du vote puisqu'on a
très souvent des scruté un public
les personnes qui ont déposé des
amendements ne l'évotent pas lorsqu'ils
sont de droite donc il y a une consigne
très claire de faire bloc de ne pas
s'exprimer d'attendre que ça passe
[Musique]